Julian talk to me yes popped into a
restaurant and when I walked up to the
the host table I actually I thought
Gerard Butler was the host so I asked
him for a table for two and he just
laughed at me not in a real rude way
kind of thing just knew like I didn't
know who he was I guess or whatever and
then kind of walked away that was the
breath of the entire universe okay so
when he sat down and you sat down how
close Were You by by that point probably
he might have been about like 15 feet
away you know like it was not like he
was like the next table but it was just
a couple tables that's pretty close
though yeah I mean that'd be awkward
after getting blown off by the guy to
then be I don't think he's peripheral
eye lines yeah I mean we definitely had
what did you say you ordered I think it
was like it's a chicken and waffles kind
of thing okay what did he get oh I don't
know